welcome to another thankful Thursday I
believe is important to thank the people
in your life for helping you make this
business happen because you can't do it
alone
and so take some time every week to say
thank you to those people who are
helping you get along the way now today
is a little different one today I want
to thank the little man and you may be
thinking the little man why am I
thinking a little man
the little man is the guy who tells you
all the reasons why your ideas not gonna
work out who tells you you're not good
enough who doesn't believe in you who
just brings negative energy everywhere
he goes
so why don't I want to thank him today
because the little man is fuel the
little man can motivate you the little
man has caused me to create great things
in my business and in my life see
there's two ways to motivate people one
is the positive right positive to think
of all the great things that you want to
accomplish all the people you're going
to impact you like why are you doing
this you're gonna figure your wife and
your kids in your country and your
family and and the people in your
community and one of the great goals you
have you all want to I want to
accomplish this in my life this is these
are all the people I want to touch write
all the positive things and
entrepreneurs are naturally optimistic
and driven and big-picture thinking and
want to have an impact right we want to
have an impact that's why we're doing
this business instead of working a
nine-to-five jobs slowly killing
ourselves but the other side is a
negative and you can use rallying around
an enemy to drive you forward to create
amazing things to give you the fuel to
want to show them and say I can do this
so the next time somebody comes and says
you're not good enough you're not gonna
make this this is such a stupid idea
look at all the holes look at all the
errors you know this is never gonna work
out who do you think you are to be able
to do this just say thank you
use that as fuel and then go show the
belief you guys like this video
subscribe below to see more just like it
thanks so much for watching I'll see you
soon don't forget to check out my
newsletter like below
hi I'm Jason Grif on sigur rós
online.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's only newsletter I
prioritize and look forward to period